[Music]
I like that song so much just keep it
going right Lee Greenwood Thank You Lee
and I want to thank everybody Jeff for
the beautiful introduction what a job
you and everybody have done it's great
to be here with the incredible men and
women who are making America into the
energy superpower of the world we've
just gone to number one not so long ago
few months ago this was not gonna happen
with somebody else in office that I can
tell you I was saying things that took
25 years before they got disapproved in
other words had worked on it for 20-25
years and then they wouldn't get
approved we're getting them done in less
than a year and if they're not good for
the environment they won't get approved
they will get approved but at least
you'll know one way the other we're
getting them done quickly or well
letting them know they don't work but
we're finding it most of them do most of
them do and today we celebrate the
amazing workers at Sempra Energy as you
open the Cameron LNG export facility for
business I've never seen the thing like
this in my life this is incredible
[Applause]
and knowing the group very well that did
it they have two more phases that
they're probably gonna be starting
pretty soon I know I shouldn't say that
Jeff but that's the way it is from right
here and hackberry Louisiana you will
very soon be exporting clean American
natural gas all over the globe with the
incredible grit skill and pride the
7,000 workers at this facility are
helping lead the American energy
revolution that's what it is number one
in the world not even close and you know
I just approved a lot of pipelines going
through Texas and other places including
as you know the Keystone XL pipeline I
approved the Dakota access pipeline
these were lines that were worked on for
a long time and they never would have
happened we did a my thinking my first
week and it's great that's great and
it's clean and it's environmentally
better than the alternatives you know
that in Louisiana Texas New Mexico
Colorado North Dakota Ohio Pennsylvania
and states all across our land workers
like you are lighting up our homes
powering our factories and reducing
energy costs for hardworking American
families you are not only making our
nation wealthier but you are making
America safer by building a future of
American energy independence we are
independent we don't need anybody we
don't need anybody
[Applause]
and we don't need to be ripped off by
the rest of the world either because
those days are over
you know I went around I used to
especially in my previous life I'd go
around I'd see these airports in
different countries the most incredible
airports in the world then I'd come home
I'd land at LaGuardia I'd land at
Kennedy or Newark or I'd land in LAX and
they are not the same we used to be the
leader but we're gonna be the leader
again we have things designed right now
that nobody would have ever believed we
will be the leader again and it's gonna
happen very quickly and it's already
happening and by the way this is a big
factor when you look right behind me
it's really happening because few people
have anything like this anywhere in the
world and now instead of relying on
foreign oil and foreign energy we are
now relying on American energy and
American workers like never before and
you know we work with other countries
that we work with their energy and we
take their energy we buy it we produce
it but we don't need to if we don't have
to if we don't want to it just works out
pretty well that way but anytime we want
we can stop the energy we produce here
in our country is better cheaper and
cleaner than our foreign competitors and
it's not even close you people know that
better than anybody it's your business
we're thrilled to be joined by many of
the great leaders from Louisiana a state
I love very much and based on the votes
I should love it very much
[Applause]
and I do love it and I love the people I
love the people of Louisiana very
special people thank you darling thank
you very much thank you
I even like that guy that just said it I
want to just introduce some of my
friends some of my warriors they're
warriors and they really helped me a lot
you know we've done a lot nobody has
done more the first two years of an
administration no matter where the fake
dues back they look at all of them back
to a fake news they're gonna be very
famous they're gonna be very famous
tonight some will go and sign movie
contracts tonight look at these guys but
we have great people in there they're
tremendously talented Senator John
Kennedy John thank you thank you John
he's a tremendous man Senator Bill
Cassidy dr. Bell dr. bill nobody knows
more about healthcare and medicine
whenever I have a question I'm sorry
John we call that man you do and I do
because there's nobody like bill for
that and we're working on some great
things and thank you very much bill you
and John and the whole group also a man
who's perhaps braver than I am House
Republican whip Steve Scalise
I hate to admit it now I hate to admit
it I hate to admit it folks but he got
you know he was playing in the baseball
game against the Democrats and he was
not in such great shape but he wouldn't
miss it and he's at a big stadium that
was at the stadium right and I couldn't
believe it I was watching it on
television secret services you can't go
Sarah let it go but they said you can
he's standing at second base not the
first batter but the first pitch he gets
a shot hit right at him but it was hard
I said I don't believe it
I couldn't see where the ball was going
but I could see it was going to second
and I knew who was standing in second
Steve and Steve went through a little
problem right I saw him that night and
it looked like he wasn't gonna make it I
knew that night that his wife loved him
because she was crying like I've never
seen a woman cry before I call I said
Steve about a month later I said Steve
your wife and family loves you because I
know some cases where it's not quite
that way
not quite in fact sometimes you see
smiles on their faces there and I say to
that B if you're in trouble this isn't
working it but you have a great family
but the balls hit - Steve really hard
and all of a sudden they show a picture
he's on the ground that ball is right
there he picked up that ball and he got
it and they made it out I said that's
the most incredible thing and I compared
him to the great Bobby Richardson twelve
years in the New York Yankees he had the
greatest range of any second base
whenever they say he'd field them behind
shortstop he'd failed them so Steve can
only move about six inches but I'll tell
you what there was no chance that that
ball was going through right there no
chance he got it out and then they did
something very smart they took him out
of the game he came out like the biggest
hero one out you're the greatest if I
appreciate it and everybody in this
country appreciates you okay brave guy
red God and another brave and hardened
representative somebody that's helped us
all the time play
Higgins play thank you for we got some
good ones over here Thank You clay Mike
Johnson Mike thank you Mike
fantastic job highly respected Thank You
Ralph
Abraham Ralph great job Ralph and Garret
graves thank you very much thank you
thank you guys thank you that's a great
group of people they really helped us we
got a lot done tax cuts and regulation
cuts without the regulations I hate to
say it but you wouldn't be looking at
these monster beautiful pieces of art
because I call them pieces of art thanks
also to Louisiana lieutenant governor
Billy Nungesser where's Billy
rosy Billy thank you thank you for
Attorney General Jeff Landry thanks Jeff
thank you Jeff an agricultural
Commissioner Mike strain thank you very
much thanks mark
you got good people here also with us is
Deputy Secretary of Energy Dan brew yet
Dan Ben
good job good job and we have some of
our big people from around the world
because you're gonna be selling energy
all around the world
Louisiana starts here and then it goes
around the world our ambassador to the
European Union Gordon sunlen Thank You
Gordon where is he great job good and he
brought along the vice president of the
European Commission
mara SEF can vouch ma thank you very
much thank you
the European Union I said before they're
just as tough as China there's just a
little bit smaller they're pretty tough
too they're all tough you know when they
look at your country is not being strong
from certain standpoints like when they
used to take an advantage of your
country they all get very much tougher
than they should be but that's all
changing very quickly amazing how
quickly I especially want to thank
semper energies chairman and CEO Jeff
Martin Jeff that was great what you said
and what you've done thank you for the
tour
your company president Justin bird and
your chief operating officer Lisa
Blatche that was a great tour thank you
Lisa thank you very much thank you very
much great tour he's not long ago that
Sempra plan to build a natural gas
import terminal on this very spot that
was in the past where our leaders
pursued policies that were anti-american
energy an anti-american worker and anti
America wealth it all ended but those
days are over now we have an America
first energy policy just like we have an
America first policy it's music to
people's ears so we believe in unlocking
our nation's resources empowering our
country's workers and bringing back our
wealth because our wealth was taken our
jobs were taken our plants were closed
and then they'd come back build a
product and sell it into our country for
no tax no nothing so we lose the jobs we
lose the taxes we lose the wealth and
another country bills the product and
they send it in no tax well that's
changing you saw that that's changing
rapidly that's changing rapidly
I always said I always said maybe that's
our biggest group we have so many
supporters on that beautiful day in
November 2016 and I'm sure nobody
remembers that beautiful day does
anybody remember that's one of the
highest-rated days in the history of
television
one of the highest
one of the highest-rated days did
anybody not watch television that night
all over the world they will watch it
but soon when this facility is fully
operational you'll export up to 15
million tons of liquefied natural gas
every single year that's a massive
amount one of the biggest in the world
to put that massive capacity in
perspective this facility alone could
soon supply over 40% of the natural gas
Germany imported from Russia in 2017 or
25% of the LNG imported by the European
Union than 2018 see that will sell you a
lot of natural gas there's only one
problem Jeff told me you sold out for 20
years can you believe it you sold out
right so we can't sell them anything
more can we you better build those
additional monsters please got to get
started under there come on Jeff what's
taking so long sold out for 20 years
like an office building but you make
more money and boy I'll tell you it's
great for the country this extraordinary
turnaround as possible because under my
administration we have ended the war on
American energy and we have ended the
economic assault on our wonderful energy
workers and you are under assault
[Applause]
and now they talk about the green New
Deal the green New Deal everybody go
home you just lost your jobs the green
new deal is that's a hoax like the hoax
I just went through I'm not even sure it
might be a bigger one and mine was
pretty big mine was unlimited
think of it the green new deal under
that deal I didn't have this this isn't
down
but John Kennedy bill under that deal
everybody in this room gets fired all of
the thousands of guys and women standing
on these buildings get fired they go
home because under the green New Deal
they don't like clean beautiful natural
gas they don't like anything they don't
know what they like they sort of like
wind even though it kills all the birds
you want to see a bird cemetery go under
a windmill sometime you'll see the Santa
so you got every type of bird you know
in California you go to jail for five
years if you kill a bald eagle you go
under a windmill you see them all over
the place not a good situation but
that's what they were counting on wind
and when the wind doesn't blow you don't
watch television that night your wife
said what the hell did you get me into
with this green new deal charlie by
unleashing American oil natural gas and
clean coal workers like you are helping
to fuel America's historic economic boom
that's what it is it's never been
anything like this and all over we have
plants going up of different kinds we
have the greatest economy in the history
of our country
last month we created another 263
thousand jobs crushing expectations The
Wall Street geniuses said maybe 160
that's pretty good by the way now we
beat a by a lot and since the election
we created nearly 6 million jobs
including 57,000 new or
and gas pipeline construction jobs and
in 2018 alone America added over 150,000
brand-new energy jobs and I told you
great senators that if we get elected if
I win my race so we get it just the way
we want it and I think we're gonna win
it big I'm looking at the competition
you sort of dream about competition like
that but who knows oh no I got booed
edge edge I got them all
I got beta theta betas falling fast what
the hell happened remember about four
four weeks ago he said I was made for
this he was made for it he was made to
fall like a rock he what happened to him
but he's trying to restart his campaign
that generally doesn't work out too well
political geniuses when you have to
restart your campaign history has said
that that does not work out well right
history has said that that's trouble but
he's gonna restart his campaign but I'm
looking at it I don't know what the hell
happened to Biden what happened to him
I'm looking at I said that doesn't look
like the guy I knew what happened to him
and Bernie you know Bernie's crazy
but Bernie's got a lot more energy than
Biden see you never now know now
Bernie's got a lot of energy but it's
energy to get rid of your jobs
he's got the opposite energy that you
produce not good energy you're like his
energy but you know so it's gonna be one
of these people pocahontas I think is
probably out well you got some beauties
here 350 million people and that's the
best we can do I don't think so even as
Democrats I could pick better than that
in the first quarter of this year the
economy grew an annual rate of three
point two percent smashing projections
remember they thought it would be about
one first quarter is always the lowest
they thought it would be about one and
then the day of they said but you know
we're doing really well but maybe it'll
be up to two maybe one and a half right
fellas and then it came out 3.2 and
everybody was freaking out except me I
said you know we're doing really well
and again the first quarter is always
the weakest almost always it's the
weakest quarter so 3.2 percent now what
I ran they were all saying you can't say
3% and last year we hit three percent
for the year and we had one month at
four point two percent and frankly if
interest rates would come down a little
bit would do five percent if I get a
little help need a little help
gotta get my little help there I'm not
gonna be a wise guy I want a little help
little lower interest rate a little
quantitative easing just a little bit
would hit five unemployment is at its
lowest rate in 51 years
[Applause]
african-american Asian American and
Hispanic American unemployment have
reached all-time historic lows never
lower in the history of our country so
let's say right so let's say I'm on the
debate stage we start talking and I say
well you know we have the lowest rate
ever for African American for Asian for
Hispanic all I have to do is say that
and walk off the stage I guess you
wouldn't the debate who's going to beat
here that in the history of our country
they're the best unemployment rates and
for the first time in a very long time
wages are actually rising I would talk
during the campaign that people that
work 21 years ago one job would make
more than they were making three years
ago before I got things going and they
would make more money from 21 years ago
than they did three years ago they had
three jobs and two jobs and now they're
making money and they're also having
choice you know I got the veterans
choice first time in 44 years the
veterans have choice
where they can go pick a doctor have to
wait online fit for weeks they can go
pick a doctor instead of waiting for two
days three they have to wait they go out
pick a doctor and we paid the bill and
we actually I don't want to say cuz I
don't do it for that reason but we
actually saved a lot of money but we're
taking care of our veterans well we have
the same choice on jobs because now not
only a wage is rising but very
importantly you've got a choice of jobs
if you don't like what you're doing you
gotta want to wake up I do despite all
of the stuff that we go through and
despite being in the swamp of Washington
and it is a swamp but we are knocking
the hell out of the swamp creatures as
we call them we're knocking the hell
they've never had a time like this they
say what the hell is going on but I love
getting up in the morning I love what I
do because I'm doing a service for
millions of people and I love it well
jobs are the same thing you gotta love
it and if you don't love it get
something else so not only do you have
rising wages you have choice you can go
out if you're unhappy with your job you
don't like the boss you don't like
something go out you have six seven
eight alternatives and you'll find
something that you really do love and
you really do look forward to waking up
in the morning and going to work last
year a record seventy-three percent of
newly employed workers were people out
of the workforce who were coming off the
sidelines
the previous administration tried to put
America's vast energy resources under
lock and key
we don't want energy I don't know what
they were thinking and they tried to put
energy producers out of business but no
more it's a great business it's a vital
business for our country we're opening
up Anwar in Alaska one of the biggest
sites anywhere in the world
they've been trying to get that approved
since before Ronald Reagan nobody could
get it approved Ahnold Reagan couldn't
get it approved nobody could get it
approved we got it approved and they're
working on it right now we're unlocking
the full oil and gas potential of the
Permian Basin in Texas and New Mexico
and sending it right here to you and you
taking it over and you're doing a good
job and you shipping it all over we
ended the moratorium that stopped new
coal leasing on federal lands we have
the folks here that are responsible for
doing that they are doing an incredible
job I withdrew the United States from
the terrible very expensive one-sided
Paris climate Accord
you just take a look at Paris the
president's a friend of mine sometimes
I'll call him up how is it doing over
there how you doing in Paris not so good
not so good the yellow vests and you
know that was all about the Accord
because they were charging people
tremendous amounts of money and sending
that money all over the world to
countries that they never heard of and
the people got tired of it I saved one
trillion dollars by not going with the
Paris Accord and I thought I'd take a
lot of heat and instead we've been
praised for not doing it we've been
praised
the Paris Accord was an agreement that
it would have shut down clean energy
production in America while allowing top
foreign polluters to do whatever the
hell they wanted it was a restriction on
America it was almost made to hold us
back and nothing's holding us back no
longer will we allow other countries to
tie America's hands and take America's
jobs and hurt America's energy and we're
replacing the EPA Environmental
Protection Agency's for those who don't
know that sound
EPA we're taking their job-killing clean
power plan it's got a beautiful title
that's where it ends which would have
actually made the environment less lean
by shifting energy production to foreign
countries so instead of doing this you
would have foreign countries doing that
and then shipping it back I don't think
that works out too well fellas what do
you think no good no good right John
says no good that means it's no good and
we're focusing the EPA on its core
mission ensuring clean air and crystal
clean water for our citizens in our air
right now is cleaner than it's ever been
[Applause]
and one of the things I told to bill and
Steve and John coming over we're in the
the beast we traveled in the Beast
I think it's the world's most expensive
army tank right the windows the walls
but they said sir
we'd love to have John Kennedy saying
whatever you could do I ten bridge you
know the i-10 bridge Chao cascoon shoe
but I like I tend much better - can we
go by I tend you mind okay
you know you've been saying that word
your whole lives me I just heard it
about 20 minutes ago
so the i-10 bridge and I say this and I
give you this commitment and I can't
play with these three Steve John bill
everybody sitting here if we win this
election which is just 16 months away
we're giving you a brand-new Iten bridge
[Applause]
[Music]
I didn't know it's gonna be that popular
and we're going to start work on it
right away because I think we're gonna
win so we want to be prepared okay so
we'll start work on it right away in
terms of planning everything and let's
do a beauty okay but it's a very unsafe
bridge a lot of problems and we're gonna
give you a new one they've been trying
to do it for a long time so we're gonna
start planning and developing right away
and we'll have it all set to go day one
right after the election okay just last
month I signed two executive orders to
cut the red tape holding back new energy
infrastructure like we see here today
without what we've done you could have
never had this approved I think Jeff
would say that very easily without what
we did you could have never gotten this
done it would have taken you many years
and I say many years prior to rejection
ago years and years the result of our
efforts has been an incredible
resurgence of the American energy
production this quarter the United
States produce record amounts of oil and
national gas I will tell you the natural
gas not even close to the oil not even
close
since the election private companies
have invested in a half a trillion
dollars in the US energy industry they
put half a trillion dollars and it looks
like it's going substantially up from
there including in this great state
where many tremendous projects of all
different types are planned and not only
in the energy business in other
businesses also in the past two years
we've expanded our LNG exports to the
world by nearly 500 percent
500
and it was heading south folks it was
heading south fast the United States has
now been a net exporter of natural gas
for two straight years and our net
energy imports are the lowest level that
we've had in over 60 years in other
words bringing it in the lowest in 60
years in 2018 American energy exports
alone brought down our trade deficit by
two hundred and fifteen billion dollars
and we're pursuing a vision not just of
energy independence but of American
energy dominance when we get those
pipelines approved you'll see it go up
30 and 40 percent from already number
one in the world by the end of next year
America's LNG export capacity will more
than double think of that but what does
it really mean it means jobs jobs jobs
that's what it means
and thanks to our historic tax cuts in
reform everybody here got a tax cut
everybody big one Sempra Energy is
bringing billions of dollars back home
to America right where it belongs
after years of rebuilding foreign
countries we are now rebuilding our
country instead and we continue to grow
the industry of the future we're
training our workers for the jobs of the
future and we're now living by two
simple rules by American and hire
American sound school and that's why my
administration started the pledge to
America's workers our partners have
committed to provide nearly 8 million
training and enhance career
opportunities to their American
workforce I'm proud to announce that
Sempra Energy just signed the pledge and
agreed to train 1,000 Americans to build
our energy future thank you Jeff for
that and we really appreciate it thank
you we want every American to know the
dignity of work the pride of a paycheck
and the satisfaction of a job well done
we do not believe in socialism okay is
that all right to say
[Applause]
if we had socialism here you'd have
nothing standing and if it was standing
from previous generations it would be
falling down right now when we have a
soaring economy millions of hardworking
people can wake up every day excited to
use their talents and provide their
families lift up their community and
strength in our country here with us
today are several tremendous workers who
want to tell us what America's energy
revolution means to them Ronald Nunez
lost his energy job over 20 years ago
back in 2015 a lot longer than 20 years
ago I mean I don't know who to help with
that but he did lose it they had the
rolling number but they had the right
number of years 20 years where's my
speechwriter congratulations thank God I
don't read it too often thanks to our
great 20 years think of that thanks to
our great energy revival he's now back
to work he's working hard he's making a
lot of money
Ronald please come up tell your story
please come
[Applause]
afternoon everyone my name's Ronon enas
I wanted to tell you about my journey
here to see LMG for Cameron elegy for
over 20 years I've worked at a plant
just a few miles south of here
and I plan to retire there and then the
news came
because the news came of lack of gas my
plant would be shut down November the
30th 2015 and every all employees would
be terminated effective immediately
with one weeks notice two weeks paycheck
in my pocket I went home and very
concerned for my family's future we
didn't have any health insurance
in fact we would look towards the
Affordable Care Act which would be
really good in the fourth
after seven after several months worry
stress
Cameron LNG's job fair hired me and many
of my co-workers great great benefits
great benefits great savings plan great
health insurance
thanks to Cameron LNG and the now
growing natural gas industry my family's
future were once again restored
[Applause]
thanks thanks to Cameron L&G and the
president's policies the president
United States I'm proud to be a part of
this this endeavor
operate a world-class facility
distribute LNG around the world
[Applause]
great job that's from the heart you're
gonna run for office are all wrong
they'll be announcing tomorrow be
careful fellas great job thank you
I'd also like to invite Cat Stevens who
retrained and found a job here when she
needed it most
it's got a tremendous story to tell and
I want to thank you cat and also cat
where's Kent okay
whisky come up here Kent come up
[Applause]
hello everyone my story is more of a
journey than a story it started in 2014
when my husband lost his awful job who's
a Drilling Supervisor 13 years in ours
like Walla was it was immediate we have
seven children from college to
elementary school no income no insurance
was a lot I went to job fair and met
several people from Cameron LNG and
decided at that point I needed to go
back to college so I went to swellow
Community College here in Lake Charles
and with the support of my family my
parents especially and my husband
graduated ahead of time got to do my
internship out here and just absolutely
fell in love with everybody out here the
culture the people everything they stand
for and as soon as I graduated mr. dan
Callens hired me and I've been here ever
since and it's just it's fabulous
everything that they stand for they do
Li do truly stand for safety above all
because they realized that I have a
family to go home to everyone out here
has a family to go home to we're all
children of someone and that means a lot
to me it really does and mr. Trump and
Sempra thank you so much for everything
you've done and thank you for your
energy independence
[Applause]
Thank You cat thank you very much that
also with us is Nicole fries Nicole
please come up have a great story to
tell thank you very much
hello Thank You president Trump for
inviting me to share my experience at
Cameron LNG as they stand here today and
look around
I am truly amazed but what has been
accomplished by the Cameron LNG team
just a few years ago we were all
standing in a marsh today we stand
beside the newest addition to the United
States energy infrastructure our
world-class LNG facility represents so
much to me
overcoming obstacles family and teamwork
at the top of my list in 2017 during the
construction of this facility I was
diagnosed with a very aggressive form of
breast cancer 35 days after my initial
diagnosis I was undergoing major surgery
which was just the first step of many in
the battle to save my life
the people at Sempra and Cameron LNG
rallied around me immediately they
brought food for my family they helped
with the care of my young children they
donated money to support us and they
sent constant words of encouragement and
prayers the moment I was ready to come
back to work
I was received with open arms back into
my position which they had held for me
for eight months I'm so grateful for the
support from the team at Cameron LNG for
me being employed at Cameron feels like
working for a mom-and-pop shop but with
a fortune 500 backing so many doors of
opportunity have been open for me and my
family as the industry continues to grow
I'm so proud to be a part of the team at
Cameron and Sempra I would like to thank
President Trump for all he has done to
help us start building infrastructure
again thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much and through the hard
work of people like Ronald and Kat and
Nicole and every Patriot here today we
are making life brighter and better for
all Americans and I just think the three
of you thank you very much what a great
job great inspiration thank you
[Applause]
but despite all of this exciting news
there were some in this country who are
more determined than ever to put America
energy out of business you know that
over 100 Democrat members of Congress
have sponsored that green new deal a
radical plan if you've ever heard it
they want to put you out they want to
stop coal they want to sell oil they
want to stop nuclear they want to stop
practically anything on my watch we will
never let radical activists special
interests and out-of-control bureaucrats
wreck our economy eliminate our jobs
would destroy your future we won't let
it happen and these people will not let
it happen they won't let it happen we
know that American energy workers like
the ones here at Cameron LNG are the
foundation of American strength that's
what you are the foundation of our
strength as we embrace the potential of
our country's god-given abundance we are
also strengthening our national security
by reducing our dependence on foreign
sources of energy we have dramatically
increased our power to confront our
adversaries support our friends and
fight for our interests for example
American allies all around the world
like in Poland and Lithuania are now
using American natural gas to reduce
their dependence on countries who use
energy as a weapon of coercion in
Venezuela and Iran we're now holding
dangerous regimes accountable by denying
them oil revenue to fund their
corruption oppression and terror since I
took office the United States has
increased oil production by over 3.2
million barrels per day that's an
incredible number
and that 3.2 million barrels completely
surpasses the crude oil exports from
Venezuela and Iran and we've subtracted
that from the world market until such
time as things work out and worked out
properly for those millions of people
unfortunately politicians in California
New York and other states risk our
economy and our national security by
blocking vital energy resources from
being developed an energy infrastructure
like this from being built these states
could be ports for shipping energy to
our friends and allies but instead of
helping our partners they're hurting
America I have a simple message for
these politicians that do such damage to
our country we should be producing
energy at home not enriching foreign
adversaries abroad that's what we're
doing we're making a lot of people
wealthy but it's getting less and less
wealthy every week and they should be
supporting great American workers like
you and the astonishing changes that
you're making possible with your own two
hands just a few days ago you began work
on your first shipment of American
natural gas extracted by American
workers and transported through American
pipelines as it came in your train teams
began to liquefy the gas cooling it down
to 260 degrees below zero when the
process is done you will load that LNG
onto a tanker and from there
the first shipment of Cameron LNG will
travel down the Gulf of Mexico through
the Panama Canal and off to Asia to
eliminate cities on the other side we
will have such illumination like you
haven't believed they're going to be
illuminated like never before they're
talking about it they're excited some of
the countries don't have lots of money
we're making good deals that were making
things possible for the
the energy revolution that you're
leading is an incredible story and it
could only be written right here in the
past pundits and politicians claimed
that America was running out of oil and
natural gas that was saying it ten years
ago five years ago I was hearing it all
the time
they said the United States would never
again be an energy powerhouse they said
that Americans would have to learn to
get by with much much much less but you
proved them wrong when American workers
were given the chance you silenced the
critics and shattered the predictions
now thanks to America and thanks to all
of the great permits and approvals and
financing and all of the things we've
been able to do together America is
working
America is thriving America is booming
and America is winning like never before
you are powering our cities uplifting
our nation and you are lighting up the
world you're building a better future
for our families and for our children
and for every Patriot and you are true
patriots who salutes our great American
flag you're making America safe prouder
stronger and greater than ever before I
just want to say this has been a great
honor to be with you today this is a
special day this is your first day in
many many many days of producing
something that is very special it's a
tremendous achievement I want to
congratulate everybody involved in this
project and most importantly I
you
and I want to congratulate the workers
because ultimately it doesn't work
without the workers thank you god bless
you and God bless america thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
prescription three
[Music]